okay we're booting this back up for a
little
bit meeting got pushed but
um I want to get this
this the only way to do this is going to
be to
forward now I have to come up with some
data for this so uh let's just do data
equal
it's kind of awkward data isn't it as
well for. a
range
uh it's 10 agents
times 11 * 11
*
4 + 26 I
believe would be pars like this
percent
16 and then we reshape
it like
this no it doesn't get
reshaped it just is flat
right and
then we
do the state as
well let's start with this
dumb float I believe yeah it's a float
you do like
this input type
right uh map device CPU
welcome YouTube
folks schedule's getting all chopped up
today with stuff I got to do but I
figure we'll try to get this done right
multiple they're the actions
right and we can see that we get these
as outputs
out I think I need to print out at every
feat at every uh layer don't
I yeah and to print out stuff at every
layer
oops over.
C okay so in the forward pass
here we just have to print some stuff
right so first we got to
percent percent
FN and then we do OBS
2D 0 0000
Z which really we should just yeah we
could do like this OBS
1D then what we do is print
um output zero yeah this is what we
yeah we just want to check the first
element of
everything that's not a foolproof check
but like that should get us most of the
way I would imagine
and then we have to exit here so we have
to like there's no exit function
now uh wait we also have to do we have
to give it the fake data don't
do I less than num agents * 11 * 11 *
4 and then what we do is n of
observations map of I we have to set it
to the same dummy data I
yeah oh that's kind of gross though
isn't
it because you don't have any way of
taking into account the flat data like
this do
you well that's
awkward um uh how am I going to do
awkward cuz I have two separate
observations here right
on there's got to be a smart way of
doing this
now think you'd think so but you'd be
wrong uh
now I'm going to get if I do it this way
I'm going to get the data wrong and then
I'm going to spend forever debugging the
stupid data like I'm going to be
debugging I'm going to be debugging the
test
okay here's an
idea I can do the first row
something and now all I need to do is I
replicate that
here basically already done
it's like how am I supposed to debug
through something of this
size really obnoxious as well that I
decided to
uh to save the network in the way that I
did all
print actually that 2D observation
is yeah so what we're going to do is
print CNN
let's see what this looks
like okay so observations 2D is correct
observations 1D is
different already we have a
discrepancy why is there already a
discrepancy
because
no oh why did this go to 256 freaking
auto complete
man okay so now look at the data the
data is correct here and then we get out
of
con the con is wrong
though okay so why is the con
wrong the data going into the con
correct
is it should be like this
maybe
no very confused
wait
do let's just do
OBS and OBS
2D all right let's just do it this way
you know
work wait n
OBS this should be net OBS 2D
one okay so this looks good
right this 2D data matches
sense I don't know if it makes any sense
but
it's says it
is the CNN features it says it's
okay well we're not going to let that
stop us now are
this
expected
here may also reply to one thing real
quick I forgot uh I got a DM on a
shape okay this is not what I expected
to
be this should be
data and it's like interestingly close
but still too far
off the observation is small enough that
I can check all of the data though
that's the key if I'm just doing one
observation I can check the entire data
I should uh I should make use of that
luxury map
features let's do map features of zero
like
okay and then we'll
do hold
on yeah we're not going to leave any of
this to
chance we're going to make sure all the
data is exactly the
same That's How we'll have to do
it so this is going to
be 11 * 11 * *
um yeah we're going to have
to but so obnoxious the way that this
is I think we leave it like this
and then we'll just
do yeah we'll just do like this print F
OBS
2D space print
FN okay so now we can
see our data correctly here
and we're going to do the exact same
thing for
con one
one
sln and then this is going to be a ton
of data but this should tell us
pretty much
instantly what we' screwed up
here so here we have our observations
but that's too big of an error for like
numerical Precision
right
yeah it's possible that I have the bias
term wrong in my con that would do it
right I thought I tested that
though thought I tested
if I test puffer andet it passes
right what if I 10x the bias term
still
passes so according to this the coms are
correct so that leaves that I have the
data in the test
wrong or the input is wrong
You2
list try
this so I can see
exactly which should give me yep massive
list
I don't know why they're actually like
this if I think about
it's probably a bad pattern actually now
that I'm thinking about that because
uh well I guess it's going to be sparse
regardless it's a one
hot this goes on for a long time though
wait a second look no no no no this is
not I have ones down
here this is all
zeros okay the memory format's different
then right
DNN features is
19 size 19 right
No it should still print them in the
same format regardless
here memory loud is totally
different and it looks like there's
actually way more stuff in here isn't
there hang
on let's
do
oops zero do
yeah that's actually a good point here
that there aren't any
you can see that there should be extra
data at the bottom here
right be all sorts of extra
data let's see what's in the
2D n work well I just am not printing
enough of it
here but this is supposed to be
go8 the data is different down there
though as
well I can see that the end of this is
not the
same
and how about the start of
it if this is contiguous I should be
able to
see oh wait wa wait hold on down
here yeah data format's totally
different
CNN features
zero cpu.
numpy two
list okay
so we have here dense data at the
bottom did you restart stream
yeah I uh I took a little break to do
stuff actually I got to do uh I have a
meeting again in like 28 minutes or
whatever I hate having to break up the
streams like this
but it's going to be what it's going to
be
I mean we can clearly see that the data
is off
here the format of
it because like I have here dense data
at the
and then I don't have dense data here at
the
end very
yeah so you can see I don't have DCH
data when I Ravel as
well okay so let me think about how that
is the
case it should be dense
right the dimensions are
batch
channels row and
call so when you go to the
the channel should be stored
major yeah after batch it's channels
major so why wouldn't that be the case
in my uh my
thing that's got to be my pre-process
right we know my com is
memory so we can see here it's stored in
memory in this format right
here I think I'm just wrong here isn't
this like plus
one plus
2 + three isn't this it right like this
oops yeah there we
go and then it's still not the same data
though oh is it all dense now oh wait no
here it
is
matches and then what's the first thing
in this big
chunk we get 039
a one nine yeah there it goes and then
how about at the top like is this yeah
we get all these ones with blocks of
good so let's see if I do this
then we look at the
con uh con is still not
good CNN
features about the
the start of the com is
good and then by the end somehow it's
not but maybe I just have the uh the
dimensions wrong hold
on maybe I just have the dimensions
wrong
dumb I believe it's 3x3 by1 19 isn't
it we should probably just check
uh did I mess
up I messed up
here z. CNN
features oops CNN
features Z shap well just do
shaped 10 32 3 and
three so 32x 3x
3 which is correct that's 32 channels
and then three 3x3 window which is what
it's been reduced to from 11 by
11 I love how you keep pushing it for me
I question my
Insanity basis of how things well yeah
that's I did that for many years right
but then the thing is like I I've been
working in this space since I
was
16 so like at some point you realize
like you learn enough that maybe I don't
know everything here but like I know
when I don't know something right so
it's very rare that I'm making some
error because I'm like fundamentally
missing something basic right it's very
very
rare So what I have
is I basically have the ability to
confidently make progress on anything in
this space without like you know
worrying that I'm missing something
super
dumb believe me I absolutely when I
started I would have like multi-day bugs
multi-week bugs it was God awful but now
like I can pretty consistently just clip
away and make progress at stuff
okay more than a decade
really ah look at this speaking of
clipping away and making progress that
matches that matches perfectly
and would you look at that it matches
all the way to the end of the comp
net so let's see what we're doing
now but mind you the reason we had this
bug was because of this oneoff
pre-processing function though it's very
short code but it is obnoxious how easy
it is to get stuff
here I want to do in a few places I want
to get
everything I think Kira is one of
them so we'll do the flat features print
flat
the other thing that is important I
found is
like before it was so much worse
programming when I couldn't make
consistent progress I will get bored
very quickly with things if I'm making
zero
progress um or things are just too
slow so doing stuff in a way that I can
make consistent progress is very very
important because otherwise I will just
make I'll get bored and make zero
progress like I basically I can't force
myself to F to focus on something when
I'm just completely bored it just
doesn't
work so here I have like a pretty
concrete thing to do I know roughly how
to do it
so this is where we put con
outport so this is
CNN con
2 and this is just 32 Dimensions I
believe on two output
and then linear
here
for print the flat output
oops we do
this attach CPU on P
happened um something got eaten here I
think just the label got eaten but these
are correct and
four uh the flat features look
wrong which I would think is very weird
hold
on why would the flat features be
wrong no the first ones are right and
then 03
is this
like
three Uh something's weird
here flat features.
shap 10 by 32 right oh because I did 10
by 26 yeah yeah I stupid auto
complete yeah yeah that's fine so let's
just fix this I'm almost positive that
we're good now but let's just
check it's going to be so obnoxious
having to change the network
architecture I will say with this but
it's fine we'll
deal I think I entered angly in language
Zone how did I end up here keep
going it's not that bad like you get
used to it
it it's just it's very difficult for me
to articulate exactly my thought process
because like I'm doing memory addresses
and stuff in my
head I here like the memor I can teach
you the memory address logic I'm doing
in my head and all of like 10 seconds
it's literally just like you have a
certain number of channels in your array
but you have to Flat index you only get
one number to access it so if you want
like the last Dimension then it's going
to be like this the First Dimension
times the second dimension times the
third dimension times the index plus the
second dimension times the third
dimension let me just grab the
formula I'll show you it's not that
this it's just like you know uh x *
width plus y times depth
yeah it's just
that there you
go that's all I'm doing and I'm just
like thinking about the way that the
memory is laid out and just making sure
I have I'm actually accessing the data
that I think I'm
accessing so nowhere near as bad as it
looks
perfect so these
match so now all I have to do is check
the
um
yeah like you can see but you can see my
thought process right what I'm doing is
just like I'm very painstakingly going
through and like I've have the exact
same data on python side I have the
exact same data on C side and I'm just
stepping through one layer at a time and
I'm making sure that the operations
exactly match each
other and probably eventually I'm going
to
add I mean this is the type of debugging
that I do when I'm getting something to
work in the first place and then I have
a different type of test that I'll write
once I know something is working to
prevent myself from breaking again right
so like this type of thing it's very
difficult to write a test for because
like there's so many different places
stuff can be wrong and just knowing that
the final output is wrong isn't that
helpful so I do this more interactive
debugging and then when I have a piece
of code like this that's really finicky
and I really don't want to break in the
future I'll write a test to make sure
that the output is correct but not do
anything else so then if I ever
introduce something that breaks the
output right then then I can run that
and see oh okay I broke it and then I
can go back until I didn't break it and
see exactly what I did that broke
looks L then was it 128 I believe
yeah now we're going to look at this one
here which is pretty deep into the
network at this point we're going to get
the um we're going to get it working
quite soon at this
rate though I have a meeting in a little
bit here so my hope is that we'll at
least get this next layer or two
Dimension featur zero.
detach what did I go into stupid land or
something what's wrong here
no oh I just didn't run it long enough
there 76 0
47 8 6 2
perfect so all the way up until the lstm
the network is
correct isn't that lovely
now the big the big one is the
lstm
which is semi obnoxious to test
actually now that I think about
it
um cuz that's in a gross rapper isn't it
oh actually wait a second I know how I
can do it
easy
we
do in decode actions right the flat
hidden I can just print it
here the thing that's going on there is
that the lstm is introduced by like a
wrapper layer but uh the LSM output will
be what goes into fla
good we just do like
this and then we run it here
FL
hidden uh
oh the lstm is all
zero that's not
good but what did I
print I might have done something
Jank does lstm even have an output like
this
wait you know when I finish this puffer
net you all are going to be able to play
around with it you can use uh puffet to
run stuff on the web if you'd like so
that's going to be cool I get to do all
the suffering you just get to enjoy
it h
puffer oh it does have an output doesn't
it wait this literally does not have
output yeah this thing does not even use
output okay well that's a freaking joke
here it just doesn't State we better
enjoy with hard
work heck yeah bran takes a
lot I hope you're enjoying the
puffer good Puffer
H yeah State H State
C I think it's state H is what we want
right
I like how just Auto completes random
stuff right feature 10 out of
cell I do have a meeting to go to in a
couple minutes here
but I will be back after said meeting to
finish this because we're getting very
very
close oh
okay I got to get off
actually see you all in in a little bit
bye